it's the end of the week it's Friday
that means it's time for your top five
stories of the entire week I'm Dan let's
get started so you definitely know epic
games from creating it's war obviously
but they've also been working on this
theme fortnight which you may or may not
have heard of they originally revealed
that they're working on it in 2011 and
it's now out on early access it's a bit
of a weird one this one because it's
gonna if they've already said it's gonna
go free-to-play in 2018 yeah so you can
buy it right now for 40 bucks for like
the the standard version which gets you
can shoot cosmetic items and loot boxes
and stuff there's a 60 dollar version
that deluxe this is an $80 super deluxe
and a 130 to a limited edition no I know
that sounds like a lot but some of those
do include like extra copies of the base
game so you can play it with your
friends I mean it is a multiplayer you
know tower defense type game so you
probably do want to play with those I
think it's interesting it's an
interesting strategy to say that we are
gonna go free-to-play so if you want to
jump in now you can and pay for a little
bit more stuff which is I guess you know
you're not gonna be shocked in a year's
time once you've spent all this money
that all of a sudden your friends can go
and grab the same game you've got for
free so obviously with each of the
deluxe editions as well you get things
like new here our characters weapon and
customizations and stance and different
kinds of packs sir decide which one you
want or wait till 2018 and pick it up
the same so you probably know Friday the
13th is a huge cult game a lot of
support their funding support it didn't
exactly come out completely not broken
or even a little bit not broken it was
basically almost unplayable on it
especially on Xbox one right and there
was also this really strange problem
when they tried to update it that there
was a problem with the Xbox one's memory
that refused to allow it to update okay
so the developers have been working on
an update for months and they finally
push it out onto Xbox one that should
hopefully address a myriad of problems
we crashes - bugs - stuff like our Jason
teleporting behind vehicles when he
backs up into them apparently was it was
a problem that they had and to make up
for the delay the first round of content
has come out for free and there's also a
single player coming that's gonna be
free as well so I mean hopefully the
horrifying experience is now from the
actual design of the game no I think the
fact that you've spent money on a game
that you can't
so you probably heard about these then
made legacy service for World of
Warcraft where you can play the games in
like different states that it used to be
in because obviously it's always updated
officially one of these was fel mist
which rolled the game back to when the
Burning Crusade first came out in about
2007 the guy who made it spent like four
years putting the thing together
and Blizzard shut it down within just a
few hours of the server being live he
was hoping that it would stay a small
community and then you know sort of fly
under blizzards radar of course they're
using all the assets and stuffs it was
it did post and infringement cease and
desist to them and unfortunately they
weren't able to continue but yeah it was
it was very popular apparently a lot of
people wanted to play and that quote was
its interest and you know shut it down
button got me fifty to a developer on
the legacy server said that he founded a
really fulfilling experience to make the
server and it gave his life meaning I
want to be really sad that they've
brought it down I mean I actually played
on a legacy server was my only
experience playing Wow yeah I mean
there's a really cool thing I know you
know Blizzard of shutdown legacy so it
was before and then like they've had a
meeting with the people who set up the
legacy server they shot downs and then
figure out if they want to do official
legacy service and stuff and express it
that's something they probably were
interested in I guess that's the curse
of like a successful fan-made project is
if it is really good and gets really
popular chances are it's gonna get shut
down as with every game that's coming
out lately even though you haven't
played the main game yet publishers and
developers are happy to tell you about
all the extra content that you'll be
able to get into I love extra content
yeah well apparently so do the people
making more than stone because season
pass has been announced and there's a
lot of little bits and pieces in it
there is a lot there's four episodes in
there all single-player yeah and the
first one you is called episode zero and
you can get it for free if you pre-order
so and that sets up the next three
expansions which are going to start
three different characters so the first
expansion as I mentioned episode zero
the one after that is called
adventures of gunslinger Joe which does
a former pro quarterback and Joseph
stallion and then you've got the diaries
of agent death follows that one where
you'll be encouraged infiltrating Nazi
bunkers in California as an ex OSS agent
jessica valley and all these names are
incredible and the amazing deeds of
captain will
we'll round it out which will have you
dismantling a Nazi operation in Alaska
and really mukhin Stein one had amazing
ideas and cool storytelling in like a
pulpy kind of tone but it was like also
really serious and now this one's got
these cool that seem like sci-fi novels
from the 50s or something that I'm just
saw I'm excited about I'm already super
excited about Wolfenstein 2 and the fact
that there's someone called Joseph
stallion is just any the quarterback
what's your fondest memory of you and I
playing a player unknowns battlegrounds
together
it was the hiding in a outhouse for
around 20 minutes well everyone was
killing each other outside you met when
I like was on a motorbike intro towards
someone trying to knock the my buddy
instead they shot me do that I died well
that's my fondest memory but there's new
maps coming and they're working on two
new maps and Brendan Green himself who
is player unknown has said that he there
is no concrete release date because
these maps are taking a long time
because the first map that is in the
game right now it took six to nine
months to get to a playable state but
another battlegrounds news that's
actually going to happen sooner there's
gonna be an eSports tournament at
Gamescom this year and with a price
below 350 grand turn 50 grand you can
play through solo duo and squad modes
and it'll be 80 players are in three
rounds to determine the winner and while
you're there if you're going to games
come you can pick up a total of fifty
lootcrate which will go toward finding
the prize pool event costs and also some
of that will go to charity so really
it's all it's it's all it's all good for
the hiding in the toilet some money some
money that's my hotel while we hidden it
so I had no toilet when yesterday all
the finance that is it from us this week
thanks so much for joining us as always
I do remember that you can subscribe to
make sure you don't miss an episode or
any of the new Z bits and pieces and we
will see you again on Monday
[Music]